perché stanno riprendendo il mio
telefono ma giocando il soffitto
bastava stai calmo primo video del
giappone ragazzi raggiungiamo 100 mila
mi piace per il prossimo episodio
buona visione cazzo sbagliato youtuber
beni prendere pillole il mio piede e
super ok grazie grazie mi ha detto che
un piede ma la vita è calda e calda
morendo fammi vedere cos'è comprato
dagli cuffie dieci anni piace
ripasso netti è una rapina l'incontrario
si legge il draw malaj 25 libri che cosa
fare perché diceva di fare il meglio che
bisogna disegnarci quindi usai disegnare
ovviamente ragazzi non avevo alcun
dubbio mi hanno lasciato qua a guardare
tutti gli zaini da solo come un minchia
mentre tutti quanti sono a pisciare quel
momento in cui stai per andare in
giappone e vedi ceo all'aereoporto
incredibile top10 ragioni per cui la
bici è una figata
mi scusi ma l'elisa dei motivi buoni per
andare in bici amore ti chiamo per un
attimo mi scuso amici ha interrotto in
questo momento cosa senza di manu etica
ragazzi non stavo anche bloccando
perché stefano incolla
perché stefano bolla sa sempre
cosa sta facendo sì
ma gioca nintendo con ragazzi per tutto
il viaggio io ho avuto vicino
la coppia meravigliosa
il tema
cazzo detto tutto l'accoglienza
giapponese quella vera
papà mi porti a fare questa cosa no
caputo ragazzi siamo arrivati a prendere
le valigie io e stefano e ci abbiamo la
valigia grossa e la valigia grossa più
grossa di stefano tutto nei paesi
abbiamo una prigione io non c'entro
niente neanche in giappone puoi stare
tranquillo neanche in giappone stiamo
montando la testa ragazzi intervistano
anche i liberi
[Musica]
avete mai video che stanno riprendendo
il mio telefono position va in
televisione sono già molto prima cosa
[ __ ] in assoluto del giappone quando c'è
uno scaffale pieno di bibite e prendi
una bibita
quella dietro scorre hanno vinto loro
regali peraltro scuri lo ha reso pulire
e da un'ora e mezza che stiamo seguendo
suri che sta facendo da navigatore
dovremo arrivare a casa perché ci sono
distributori di cose ogni tre secondi
siamo arrivati non ci si può credere
dovrò convivere qua dentro consoli al
power ti piace la casa dove grazie papà
tu non sai come in auguro le stanze gli
olivi lo sosteneva il meraviglioso
pratica dimostrazione di come si usa al
cesso in giappone c'è un eccesso sequel
per torino contro diciamo dalla madonna
un computer edit anche i video questo
poi queste connessi fiscale per tutti
aspettaci caso di situazione il culo
fondere civica gara e questo quando di
ieri si riscalda qui in sto malissimo
bellissimo sì perché quando fai in the
troppo caldo devi raffreddarlo con il
font e vabbè ragazzi vabbè 150.000 like
a questa è la stanza di sasha lascia
ovviamente sarà nel cesso ecco ma cos'è
va bene e qui è tantissimo e se la
cucina giapponese che la fine non
cucineremo un cazzo però dove
depositiamo il cibo bongiorni simo caffè
camera mia che condivido con torri che
in questo punto stava creando un gorilla
come ultimo abbiamo la stanza di stefano
e giuseppe dormono separati e invece io
e suri dormiamo colletto attaccato
perché siamo intimi comunque ragazzi la
situazione in camera attualmente è
questa siamo arrivati da cinque minuti e
porcellini
l'organizzatore previsto molto pi
organizzato dal provino avevo dubbi ce
la vedo così 16 giorni di apple ha
aspettato questo l'ho preso in libreria
avevo preso il giorno prima mi trovo
qualcosa da fare e ci tengo a precisare
che io le cose quando le uso le uso bene
infatti ho messo il nome dell'autore
subito qua sopra pagina scossa disegnate
stesso da bambino io in realtà non so
come si disegna una persona piccola fini
l'ho fatta molto piccola
vi segnalo fatto importante successo
dell'anno in cui sei nato a parte la tua
super fondamentale venuta al mondo
polivinilcloruro cava ragazzi questi
sono stati miei attacchi d'arte durante
la seduta in aereo calze ne abbiamo io
voglio questa bellissima sono tre le
dita ma cos'è lo stai calmo c'è un
problema in tutto questo ve lo spiego
allora questo qua è sicuramente il suo
cibo in modo che abbia mai mangiato in
tutta la mia vita
c'è però un problema che lo fanno gli
standard con i guadagni sempre in
un'apposita sala giochi non posso
assolutamente riprendere ma guarda te
che cazzo sta succedendo
sta gocciolando il soffitto che cosa
succede
cosa c era in quei giochi a tono buzz
lightyear belfiore legali
[Musica]
signore e signori siamo usciti
vittoriosi dalle macchinette e oggi
posso dire di essere un uomo anch'io
perché con questo posso definirmi uomo
grazie a tutti grazie a tutti ci sono
questi distributori di lattine ogni tre
metri la clapis sonora nel nettare di
palle di toro va all'editore palle di
tolla ormai è andata e il grande
problema è allora tutto duomo attenzione
il testo in diretta
come non lo sai a messaggiare cioè mi
chiama sangue di maiale non è buono
voglio diventare gli under e chan vi
presento la porta più utile del pianeta
bellissima apri apri non ci apre come ha
quindi c'è una poké ball gigante ma gag
no sto male ragazzi che bomba
si vabbè c'è la slot machine dei pokémon
vinci i pacchetti di figurine ci siamo
ragazzi ci siamo
cosa ho vinto ho vinto nelle carte mi ha
dato delle carte arrivato così ma ho
vinto queste tre ragazzi che non intendo
più di pokemon da una vita e mezza però
non credo siano troppo scarsa io ne ho
bisogno di papà io ne ho bisogno papà
papà me lo compri papa ha detto made
keep che dorme o ai lord perché sei
masturbando un peccato perché è amico
miotto masturbi di amici il tuo non
dormi più promessa sarà così don pro
disposti come posso trasformare in tutte
le donne si basano severo e quindi
ragazzi queste sono state le nostre
prime giornate in giappone adesso
arriveranno altri video tutti quanti
bomba di cose ancora peggio e mattino
appena finito di montare il video che
avete appena visto così come devono
svegliare stefano perché mi hanno detto
di farlo che tra un po dobbiamo uscire
facciamola chiusa in camera sua e quindi
ragazzi però i costruirli sia piaciuto e
cosa mi è piaciuto al momento è un mi
piace questo quadro succedendo
giuseppe dice sono quasi undici enti
sveglio e sveglio spero vi sia piaciuto
tranquilli che non tutti gli altri
episodi di the il giappone come sede di
commissione sull'argomento vi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e co editor
nella descrizione ci sono riusciti siate
ci vediamo un prossimo video da ragazzi
che tra tosto telecomando è tutto in
giappone si capisce un cazzo va bè
ragazzi